now remember this viral moment uh just
before the pandemic or just during the
panic pandemic actually
i have no authority here jackie weaver
no authority at all
she's just kicked him out
no she's coming don't don't she kicks
him out don't
this is a meeting called by two
counsellors
illegally
they now elect a chairman no the cop
between the vice chairs here i take
charge
read the standing orders read them and
understand them
okay well uh jackie's with us now hi um
jackie this investigation has cost
eighty thousand pounds are there abouts
and it's fun that you didn't have the
authority how are you feeling about that
this morning
morning kay um a couple of things i mean
the 85 000 isn't an investigation into
that meeting
the 85 000 covers the investigation into
all sorts of complaints about three
councillors prior to the meeting and
culminating in the meeting um so i i
don't kind of entirely feel responsible
for causing um 85 000 pounds worth of
taxpayers money to be spent in a way
where it could better have been used and
the other thing is i don't think i ever
claimed to have any authority at that
meeting
chairman asked me if i was there as a
clerk or if i was the um
the proper officer and i think my
response was that i was there simply to
facilitate meeting
so i never actually claimed to have any
authority over the meeting
okay but you did sort of kick people out
because you didn't you wanted them out i
mean so you did sort of use a bit of
authority didn't you
um
yes and no i didn't actually remove them
from the meeting i put them in the
waiting room and a little bit later the
remaining counselors having elected a
chairman formally asked a resolution to
remove them from the meeting so again i
didn't directly kick them out the
meeting
and the report actually says rather than
i have no authority
um that the actions were without any
formal footing and i totally accept that
because at the time
there were no formal standing orders or
real guidance around how those virtual
meetings were conducted they were still
very new to us okay
well fascinating stuff jackie we just
wanted to get your clarification on that